[Music]
the eh-2-zed of isms populism populism
sounds like democracy in action it's all
about looking after the little guy
hearing what ordinary people want and
giving it to them Ollie's promising to
give it to them
oddly though populist is almost always a
pejorative term no one really wants the
label most populist leaders would rather
see themselves as inspiring grassroot
movements populism has been around at
least since ancient Roman times with
Emperor's lavishing money on food and
entertainment ragin circuses to appeal
to the masses the English Civil War the
French Revolution the brexit referendum
Donald Trump's rise to power all these
came from populist grounds rose of
opinion against elites and the status
quo when a populist movement gets big
enough and doesn't get what it wants it
gives the mainstream the finger by
winning an election so what could be
wrong with a charismatic leader focusing
the will of the people and millions
voting for what they believe in when Pop
hit lists
choose to vote rather than revolt isn't
this just what democracy looks like when
it's working well some people see it
that way but there's more to democracy
than voting at least more to liberal
democracy in functioning democracies
disagreement and dissent a part of the
political process political debate
involves reason evidence challenge and
argument free speech and a free press
are vital to this populist s' in
contrast love stirring hearts with
rhetoric aren't renowned for using
evidence and argument and are keen on
dividing the world into us and them
they're prone to scapegoating
journalists elites and foreigners and to
conspiracy theories about why the world
isn't as they want it to be political
opponents are dismissed as not
understanding what ordinary people want
the real danger in populism though is
that it can morph into authoritarianism
when populist leaders believe they're in
touch with the spirit of the people
haven't helped anyone who stands in
their way
the fervor of populist politics could be
truly terrifying as the French
Revolution demonstrated the philosopher
jean-jacques rousseau whose ideas
contributed to it provides a chilling
warning of where unfettered populism can
end up he declared that citizens who
disagreed with the general will of the
people should be forced to be free
that's a very long way from sticking up
for the little guy
you